投資最大的風險是什麼?就是你沒有看懂這家公司,不是什麼中美關係,也不是股市的跌宕起伏,其實就是你沒有看懂。
那我覺得第一個要問的問題就是你這一輩子能看懂幾家公司?這是很核心的,你把大的picture搞懂。
然後我看了一下那個芒格說,
他說你一生需要幾個偉大投資,
不需要太多,
四五個就夠了,
花兩年時間看懂一家公司,
要有這種耐心。
我們做風險投資其實是沒有這個奢侈的
我們是看一個月就得下單的
不下單這個公司就沒了
別人就投了
下一輪股市就高很多了
所以你怎麼樣解決這個問題
就是你怎麼解決
在這麼短的時間要真正懂得一家公司
怎麼解決這個問題呢
我們現在是找到了三個方法
第一就是你要做Winner Pattern Study
你要研究贏家的法則
第二你要做Consumer Deep Diving
就消費者深度洞察
就對用戶深度洞察
第三你就是要
我們叫Code for Competition
你要把所有的石頭都搬開看一下
你不要看一家
你把這個行業的
十家二十家全部看完
你可能就是說
你不能只建樹木不建森林
那你怎麼才能看到森林
你就把所有的樹木都建一遍
當你建了足夠多的樹木
你心裡就有那個森林
你自己是知道的
所以這三個方法呢
我再具體稍微闡述一下
就是我覺得
我們是靠認知賺錢的
其實認知可以用一個
簡單的公式來表示
第一
你的認知等於你的信息輸入
加上你的信息處理
最後等於信息輸出
那個輸出就是你的認知
那你怎麼樣提高
你的信息輸出的質量呢
有兩點
第一你信息輸入的質量要好
第二你的決策要是有科學的
我覺得對於process
我只有兩句話想講
第一你要用第一性原理
第二用長期主義
這就是整個決策的過程
有的時候我發現
這個認知它是迭代的
因為我們確實有這個現實的問題
就我可能在一個月之內
要做決策了
那我怎麼在
我不可能一個月搞懂一個公司
所以我只能是這樣子
就是我看好了這個賽道
我把這賽道所有人都見一遍
我可能見到
I don't know
我見到可能第十幾個的時候
我可能就會有一個
oh aha moment
我好像搞明白了
這個生意的身負手是什麼
那你沒有搞懂
你就不要投
我這一點特別佩服段永平同學
他就是好像是不投
這件事情做得特別極致
特別堅決
很多人說他就做不到
因為有很多
像我們這個行業
有個叫fear for missing out
就你怕投不到
那個偉大的公司
對
就在這裡面
你怎麼平衡這個fearful missing out
和你這個
投了一個什麼品用的公司
對吧
就這裡面你是怎麼樣
怎麼樣去判斷的
所以我覺得
可能有一個數字
我也一直在抓
就是說
這種偉大的公司
到底有多少個
就你一期基金
能投到幾個偉大的公司
我現在so far的learning
就根據我自己的經驗
就是說
就我們這一行做風險投資
最關鍵是你要
打到那個home run
就你要投到那個偉大的公司
對於偉大的定義
我是這麼定義的
就是第一
你投資要回報18倍
然後你單一一個項目
我們能賺到三億美金這樣子
就是我們每個家定義不一樣
那我覺得投到偉大的公司
就是說這裡面有兩個element
一個是它的頻次
就是你一個七基金
一七基金大概四五年投資
你能投到幾個偉大的公司
這叫頻次
還有一個就是叫強度
也就是intensity
就是說你投到的一個能賺多少錢
我覺得這個頻次是靠命運給你的機會
就是我們so far
作為中國的富豪投資是非常幸運的
我們趕上了互聯網
趕上了移動互聯網
現在又趕上了AI
這都是技術
technology的刷品
帶來的機會
這個其實是跟運氣
很相關的
你在哪個時代
哪個國家
你有沒有這樣的運氣
我覺得這個可能
50都是靠運氣的
那我們so far
還是比較幸運
第二個呢就是
第二個其實就是強度
強度就是說
你一旦運氣很好
投到這個偉大的公司
你能賺多少錢
這個完全決定兩件事情
一個是
你有多少股份比例
或者你投到多大的金額
第二個就拿多長時間
有沒有賺到時間的複利
所以對我們來講
如果平次是命運給你的機會
那你就take it
那我覺得這個數字
我自己感覺就不管你投多少家
可能一期基金就是三到四個
我也問過別人
有一個天使投資
就有一個天使投
他一年投150個
我問他有幾個偉大公司
他也告訴我四個
我現在已經問了大概五六個人了
他們都說是四個
我覺得這是個magic number
如果這個四個是個magic number的話
然後就看你的heat rate是多少了
對吧
我覺得最好的heat rate可能是20%
那也就是你整個投的項目
不應該超過20
這不知道是不是科學的方法
我也在思考
就是說你到底應該
投多少家公司
即使早期你
因為這裡面有一個coverage
有一個是寬度
一個是深度
因為你投太多
你就沒有時間瞭解他們
沒有時間瞭解他們
因為你不可能
比如說你對20家公司
每天都跟得那麼緊
我覺得我自己的maximum
可能就6到8家
就你覺得願意跟他花時間
從他上能學到東西
我經常跟我們的企業家
每次聊天
就兩個月聊一次
每次都是3到5個小時
我們也不是談你什麼素質
就是說你最近的吸得是什麼
然後我們compare notes
然後你的成長的痛苦是什麼
再討論一下
這種其實是個互相學習的過程
這是非常讓人快樂的
因為你在認知迭代
他也在認知迭代
我自己的經驗就6到8個
6個可能更適合一點
一個星期就7天
你6天的工作
第7天你要休息一下
所以我覺得認知的迭代
就是這個三個方法
但是我覺得
我覺得可能我們也不是做得那麼好
我經常發現我時間是
就時間不夠用
我不曉得
這可能是方法論上有問題
所以我也很多時候也是在尋找真理